hey guys it is the 9th of June my name's
Jess McDonald and you're watching games
but news the show where we've got gaming
stories hot off the presses delivered
with sarcasm and frequently failed
attempts at humor mark sup dropped
several hardware announcements today
including the reveal of a one terabyte
Xbox one and a new controller the meaty
one terabyte console will run you 400
bucks and comes with a copy of the
hopefully less broken halo the master
chief collection and no connect which
appears to have disappointed almost no
one the bundle also features a new
controller which features a 3.5
millimeter headset jack and more
responsive bumpers it's available in the
bundle and standalone in either black or
camouflage design microsoft also
announced the 500 gigabyte Xbox one has
officially dropped in price to 350 bucks
permanently although it has been selling
at that price for months already so
you'd be forgiven for not being too fast
on that one for those of you keen on the
one terabyte version it's shipping to
stores right now it seems halo 5 really
wants you to celebrate the team effort
this time around since the campaign will
be including three companion players
whether you bring your own friends or
not three Spartans either player or AI
controlled will be accompanying Master
Chief through his random heroic actions
according to game informer your
companions will be members of blue team
specifically Linda Kelly and Fred these
guys might not have the most epic hero
names but they've been around in halo
Canon previously even though they've
never been featured in a game they will
appear alongside Master Chief in
cutscenes and will receive commands from
you throughout combat alternatively your
buddy's gonna see in control of them and
each character has their own distinct
loadout as for the portion of halo 5 the
focuses on spot and lock and his hunt
for Master Chief he'll also be joined by
his own crew called fireteam Osiris
paler 5 Guardians is due out on October
27 for Xbox one
finally mirrors edge 2 details have
dropped including the fact that the game
actually isn't mirrors edge 2 after all
the newly named Mirror's Edge catalyst
may not be a sequel to the original but
catalyst senior producer Sarah Jensen
says it will dig deeper into the story
of the cardio loving protagonist faith
Johnson said of the first game quote it
was unlike anything else in terms of the
gameplay and style it had a unique soul
but as much as we loved that game we
knew it could be more it seems that the
aforementioned more will arrive within
catalyst which developer dices promise
will honor the first game while pushing
the boundaries of first-person movement
the game is drew out early next year for
console and PC let me know down in the
comments if a terabyte is enough space
for you on your console and why or why
not you can have two games but we've got
news on recommended pc specs for the
oculus rift and ready at Dawn's hopes
for a sequel to the order 1886 that's
all the good stuff that I've got to tell
you about today be sure to leave me your
thoughts and feelings down in that
comment box and I'll catch you same time
tomorrow
you